So two coins again, C1, C2. And let's say each coin has its own probability
of coming up heads. For the first coin, we're going to call it P1, and for the
second, P2. And for reasons that should be clear later, we write it as a
conditional. So that means, if the coin you're
flipping is C1, then the probability of heads
equals P1. If the coin we're flipping is C2,
then the probability of heads will be P2. Now,
this alludes to the fact that I really want
you to pick a coin here. You're going to pick
one coin, and the probability of you pick coin one, C1, is
P0. And logically, it follows the probability of picking coin two, the other
coin, is 1 minus P0. And I'm interested in the probability that
heads come up under the scenario where you first pick a coin at random and then
flip the coin. And in this exercise, I give you some very concrete numbers. P0
is 0.3, P1 is 0.5, and P2 is 0.9.